Ah ah ah
We recruited those who want to stand up against the ordinary with the legendary heroes Ah
Kono people will be our companions
There are also cute girls
Epi
ana
Eh
Soniko
Yoririn A little bit of a king As
expected, if such a situation were to occur
, zero applicants would be unpopular
.  Rumors are whispering above
and below that the hero of this world is ignorant of this world.
I wasn't being eavesdropped on, it's
tomorrow I'm
sure I'm not familiar with that
[music]
Buber doesn't seem to
be bad but it's annoying  That's right
That's why I just finished eating alone If you think I'm vertical, it's a monster's weapon
Where are you going to get stronger without your companions
Hero-sama,
this child is
my shield  Is it okay if I go to the hero of the world?